LittleBigPlanet scrapbooked world of
paper mache cardboard and middle grading
is bigger and brighter in
LittleBigPlanet 3 with more bits and
bobs to occupy your time and tickle
every last one of your fancies it's more
of the same LittleBigPlanet you've come
to know and love and despite a handful
of unfortunate glitches some seriously
sweet new additions like you gadgets and
characters keep the overall whimsy of
the game intact LittleBigPlanet 3 story
is a ground of well trodden tropes but
having the whole thing enacted with
stack people and a sentient light bulb
voiced by Hugh Laurie allows you to wave
those cliches an inventor named Newton
kidnaps a boy and makes off for the
planet Buncombe newton then releases a
trio of ancient evil titans that possess
him and the only way to save him is to
awaken three ancient heroes that first
defeated the Titans surprise surprise
newcomers odd sock toggle and sweet
Donn's
the thing about these new characters is
that while they're fun to play they're
not particularly playable or present
rather each character is confined to the
hub world in which they are unlocked for
example once you unlock odd sock in the
mangle would swap hub you can only use
odd sock in the mangle with swamp levels
the same goes for toggle and swoop but
Sackboy is playable in all worlds and in
some story campaign levels he's
mandatory each hub world also offers
only one point a small doorway at which
to swap characters I'm disappointed that
after months of being tantalized with
the idea of gathering three friends and
playing as all four characters at once
he rarely can as of Little Big Planet 3
is launched for character levels are
severely limited which is maddening and
saddening all at once if you want to
play the whole game as someone other
than sac boy
level structure itself is very basic
within each hub Sackboy has to find
marbles that when placed together will
awaken that hubs hero marbles are
rewarded for finishing main campaign
levels and when you're not marble
hunting you can explore hubs for hidden
side quests and minigames these
minigames range from go-kart building to
lemmings like challenges and that you
have to guide six or more sack boys to a
finish line each quest is introduced by
an NPC that is just as colorful and
strange as a world itself way up in
great rocket space will take that a
special gadget get it you will need some
sort of poke pad
playing multi-planet three alone is
great when your score chasing but
playing with friends is infinitely
better helping each other navigate
sticky traps and collect prize bubbles
is rewarding as it helps the game
transcend from just something on a
screen to something affecting the
real-world space you and your play
partners will shout at each other laugh
and maybe engage in some playful
competition throwing each other into
spikes or dropping them from dizzying
heights the physics are still on the too
floaty side with characters listlessly
drifting through jumps and free Falls
but once you get the hang of how each
character works it feels immensely
satisfying to land a difficult jumping
scene with toggle or complete a speedrun
with odd sock LittleBigPlanet 3 may not
be the most solid of physics based
platformers but it definitely feels good
I can't get over how beautiful this game
looks the world of bunkum is bright and
detailed NPCs are also fully voiced for
the first time in the LittleBigPlanet
series and between the myriad sounds and
sights it's like an adorable Technicolor
acid trip and a beautiful and
untouchable bubble of sunshine but it's
the level creation tools that wrap more
depths and sparkle into LittleBigPlanet
universe unlike anything we've been
given thus far user created content is
the spine of the LittleBigPlanet
franchise and sumo digital has gone to
almost unreasonable heights to provide
not only a seemingly endless well of
tools but attractive ways with which to
learn how to use them the Popat puzzle
section is a goldmine for players who
don't have or want the desire to build
levels because it succeeds in forcing
that desire onto them these puzzles wrap
tutorials for each major element in your
creation arsenal from editing corners to
deleting objects and adding poisonous
things into meaningful mini-games these
minigames yield real rewards like new
sackboy material stickers and other
goodies LittleBigPlanet 3 gives you
every reason to learn to manipulate it
and inspires you to begin manipulating
immediately as someone who is never
really good at making a game content I
was driven to try it simply because I
now knew clearly how to use it and I
stuck with it because I was no longer
blindly groping around trying to
discover how things work LittleBigPlanet
3 is entertaining and sweet but things
get sour if you run into any of its
strange bugs sack boys twitch
uncontrollably or randomly bounce around
the screen out of nowhere or fail to
respawn in certain levels a few times I
spawned behind a moving boss character
in a side-scrolling level which broke
the game and forced me to restart these
bugs can also make you lose progress and
more than once I found myself ready to
give up because I had to begin levels
again over no fault of mine it's
frustrating and taints and otherwise
engaging experience bugs and new
character scarcity aside LittleBigPlanet
3 is an enjoyable game tackling a level
with three or four players offers for
some hilarious mishaps and trials and
teamwork and even playing tool tutorials
online with a buddy has its merits all
in all the game is gorgeous to look at
and offers a genuine challenge more so
than any other franchise title today
a little demonstration
mara Bella's
come now to ziggurat I will explain
everything